[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILLBACH: All right.
I'm going to get started.
Welcome to lecture 16 of 14.13.
We talked a lot about
utility from beliefs
and how, in particular,
anticipatory utility,
utility about thinking
about the future and what
might happen in the future,
may affect people's utility.
And then how that
in turn might affect
how people, A, choose
when to consume
or when to engage in
certain activities.
Because anticipatory utility
provides some motivation
to push things forward,
at least a little bit,
so people can look forward
to positive events.
Second, we talked about
information acquisition
about the idea that people,
if they had derived utility
from beliefs, that might affect
how much information they
might want to acquire.
In particular, we
talked about the idea
that when you think about
potentially negative
information that
you might receive--
in particular, we talked
about Huntington's disease
where people had a negative
health information--
that they might not want that
information with the motivation
that they would like
to make themselves
feel better about themselves.
They might think that
the healthier than they
actually are, they
might look forward
to a healthy life at
least for two more years.
And that might depress
their willingness
to gather or
receive information.
Now we talked a little
bit about then a model
and how to think about this.
First, we talked about a
model where people did not
have the choice whether
they could manipulate
the information themselves.
So we just talked
about when somebody
wants to seek or
reject information,
but we have the constraint.
We had imposed a constraint.
Let me go back for a second.
We had a constraint imposed
where we said, well,
the person needs to be--
have-- hold correct beliefs
conditional on the information
that they have been
exposed to so far.
So essentially, that was
just an idea of, like, OK,
here's some information that
the person could gather.
But the constraint
was this number one
that I'm showing you
here is that beliefs need
to be correct, as in like
the person is a [INAUDIBLE]
conditional on the information
that they have received so far.
And then we said, well,
if you think about this,
if this is just about wanting
to gather information and be
considered so far the case where
the person could not actually
affect future
outcomes, so that's
the case of Huntington's
disease where there's no cure.
There's nothing you
can do about it.
The question was
just like, would you
like to receive some
information that's going
to happen in the future or not?
Then we-- and I'm not going to
go to this in detail very much.
We then looked at
the conditions that
are involved for when does the
person want to know about this.
And the condition
was essentially
about this function of
f of p, where f of p
was essentially the utility
derived from beliefs.
And the condition was either
if f is concave or f is convex.
If f was concave, the person
is information-averse.
If f was convex, the person
is information-loving
and would like to find
out about those things.
Now then we said,
well, consider now also
the possibility
that people might
be able to manipulate
their beliefs.
So you might say,
what are the reasons?
Why might you ever want
to hold correct beliefs?
And in the above
framework, if you
could choose what
your p is, there's
really no reason whatsoever
to not choose p equals 1.
Remember, p here
was the probability
of your health being good, of
being HD, Huntington's Disease
negative, of not
having the disease.
So if there's no
negative consequences
of what's going to
happen in the future,
surely you have
all the incentives
in the world to deceive
yourself and make yourself think
that you are healthy, right?
And so now then the
person was like, well--
and this is what
happens [INAUDIBLE]..
The expression that's here.
There's essentially f of 1,
and that's larger than f of p
for any p that are there.
And then if the future--
this is the term
here-- what is actually
going to happen in
the future, if that's
independent of your beliefs
and the sense of that's
going to happen anyway,
you might as well
make yourself believe
that p is large.
P is 1.
You're healthy.
Now then what we left things
at was the question of,
why might you not want to
choose f of one anyway?
Why might you not want
to say p equals 1?
And that's a question to you.
AUDIENCE: If your belief
of what's going to happen
might affect the future outcome
in a negative way, you--
I guess if there
were a treatment
available for
Huntington's disease,
you would rather know
whether you have it.
FRANK SCHILLBACH: Right.
So Huntington's is not the
greatest of all examples
that I chose to start with,
because there's no cure.
But you're right.
For example, in
particular, for diseases
such as HIV or the
like, surely it
would be very helpful to know.
Because then you can engage
in proper treatment that might
actually help you get better.
Presumably, you only
get the treatment
if you actually know
what the disease is like.
In the specific
Huntington's disease,
we also talked
about a few things.
We talked about other actions
that you might be able to take.
For example, if you are
able to save for retirement,
if you are able to go to
travels before you get sick.
Or there was questions
about whether people
want to have children, questions
about like what partners
they want to be with
and so on and so forth.
So if there's a bunch of
other economic choices,
or other choices in life that
depend on whether the person is
positive or negative, it
seems like that person
should want to know.
And then deluding yourself
might get in the way
of making optimal decisions.
But broadly speaking,
just to summarize,
if there is no action
item, as in like if there's
some information about
the future that where
really, even if you
knew the information,
there's nothing you
could do about what's
going to happen in
the future, it's
not obvious why you not want to
just delude yourself and think
like things are rosier.
The world is looking
better than it actually is.
Because it might just
make you happier, at least
in the moment, even if
things in the future
might turn out to be bad.
And so this is what we
already just discussed.
So incorrect beliefs can
lead to mistaken decisions.
Well, that's correct, but sort
of overly positive beliefs
are an economically
important indication
of utility from beliefs.
That is to say on the
one hand, you might--
and this is what
we just discussed--
you want to believe that
you're healthy if it makes
you feel better about yourself
or the currently or the future.
So you might want to convince
yourself that that's the case.
But this is what we just said.
Overoptimism distorts
decision making
in some ways-- for
example, health behavior,
whether you want
to seek treatment,
but also whether
you want to adjust
to potentially bad events
and some other ways
in economic choices.
So you might not want
to-- so you might not
want to be overoptimistic
because of those distortions.
And then the
optimal expectations
will then trade off
these two things.
On the one hand, you're healthy
and maybe happier right now,
thinking you're healthy.
On the other hand-- or thinking
that the future will be bright
anyway.
On the other hand,
it might make--
change your choices
in some bad way.
Now, there was another
reason that people mentioned,
which was potential for
disappointment, right?
If you think the
future is always
going to be great, even if
you can't effect it in any way
well, at some point
reality is going to set in,
and then you might get
really disappointed.
We haven't really talked
about this very much.
That's a way in
which you can think
about perhaps people potentially
choosing their reference point.
So if you think people have
referenced dependent utility,
and if you're really
overoptimistic
very much in a way that allows
you to potentially choose
your expectations and
your reference point.
And then you might not want
to be overly optimistic,
because your reference
point might be then
too high and any
outcomes that you're
gonna eventually receive
you might sort of view worse
because you expect and
believe things to happen.
So to the extent that
being true, or being overly
optimistic leads
to disappointment,
you might not want to engage in
overoptimism, even if there's
nothing you can do
about the outcomes,
because of that
potential disappointment.
But in general for
decision making
with anticipatory
utility, at least
some overoptimism leads to
higher utility than realism.
Because essentially it makes
you feel better in the moment.
But there's this
trade off potentially
with how good you feel in the
moment versus how disappointed
you might be in the future in
case you're too overoptimistic.
Any questions about this?
Oh, sorry.
OK, so then let me show you some
other overoptimistic beliefs
in addition to the evidence
[INAUDIBLE] showed you.
So there's a classic
study by Weinstein
[INAUDIBLE] that
asks students to make
judgments of their
students' chances
for a number of outcomes.
It's similar to the question
that I had asked you
at the beginning of class.
There are two measures
that Weinstein uses.
One is what's called
comparative judgment.
This is-- excuse me.
This is how much
more or less likely
the average student
thinks the event will
happen to them relative
to the average student.
And the second one
is what's called
the optimistic/pessimistic
ratio, the number of students
who think their
chances are better
than the average classmates
divided by the number who
think their chances are worse.
So these are both sort of
measures of overoptimism.
They measure slightly
different things,
but they're broadly-- they're
fairly highly correlated.
So what does Weinstein find?
Clear evidence of
overoptimism when
you look at different
things about stuff that's
going to happen in your
life, owning a house, salary
of larger than $10,000 a year--
I think this is 1980.
That's been a while ago--
traveling to Europe,
living past age 80 and on.
The comparative judgment
is always fairly high.
So that number would be 0
if people were, on average,
realistic.
Remember, comparative judgment
is how much more or less likely
the average student
thinks the event will
happen to them relative to the
average actual average student.
And the
optimistic/pessimistic ratio,
that should be one if people
were not overoptimistic.
It's also clearly a large N1.
Remember, that's the
number of students
who think the chances are better
than the average classmates
divided by the number who
think their chances are worse.
But it works for
positive events,
but also works for
negative events.
So when you ask people about
drinking problems, suicide,
divorce, heart attacks,
all sorts of bad things,
people think they're
now, of course,
less likely to happen to
them, these kinds of events.
And then they end up
optimistic/pessimistic ratio,
that's positive.
That's just because it's like
the optimist flips, so people
are way more optimistic, or--
about-- they think
they're not going
to have drinking problems, get
divorced, get heart attacks,
and so on.
So people tend to be very
optimistic about their future
lives compared
with when you asked
them to compare it to others.
Now there's other
examples of that.
Couples believe
there's a small chance
that their marriage will end.
Small business owners
think their business
is far more likely to succeed
than their typical similar
business.
Smokers understand the
health risks of smoking
but don't believe this risk
applies specifically to them.
There's a long list of kind
of these kinds of behaviors.
People tend to have
very-- hold rosy beliefs
about their future, even
in the presence of a sort
of objective information.
So even if you give
people information
about the health
risks of smoking,
they understand
the health risks.
But then they're
like, well, that's
not going to apply to me.
Of course, there's no good
reason to actually dismiss.
It should apply to anybody.
So people just want some
things to be true presumably
because it makes them
happier in some ways.
So then beyond future
prospects, people also
tend to have overly positive
views about their abilities
and traits.
So, for example, 99% of
drivers think they're
better than the average driver.
94% of professors at the
University of Nebraska
think they're better teachers
than the average Professor
at the University.
I don't know what this
number looks like at MIT,
but probably it's larger
than 50%, as well.
So [INAUDIBLE],, you can
find this kind of evidence
from a range of domains.
In some cases, there's some
other potential explanation
for this, but broadly
speaking there's
a pretty robust
evidence that people
are overconfident,
overly positive about,
A, what's going to happen to
them in the future, and B,
about thinking about their
own skills and abilities.
Now if you look at MIT
students, however, in
contrast when you ask about
students different questions,
and this is from a recent
survey from a few years
ago that MIT asks students.
One question here
is academically,
I would consider myself
above average at MIT.
People say about 31% of students
say they're above average.
In particular,
female students tend
to think they're below average.
People might have biased
beliefs about the average.
So what you think is an average
MIT student might actually
be like the fifth or whatever,
some of the highest percentile,
because essentially you're
exposed to all the success
and math Olympics
and whatever, wins
that people receive,
which is just not what
the average student is like.
There's, of course, also
very severe selection
in terms of there's so many
smart and brilliant people
at MIT that, in a way, people's
perception is quite biased.
The questions here were asked
about the average at MIT,
but even there I think
people might just
be biased in terms of
thinking what's the average.
There might also be some
worries about disappointment
in the sense-- and this is
what I was saying before--
when you think about
being overconfident,
maybe in some ways--
so one issue with, or one
reason why you might not
end up being overconfident
for a long time
is if you receive feedback.
And at MIT, people
receive lots of exams
and so on where you can learn
or interact with others,
but you can notice how
people are doing overall.
And if you're worried
about being disappointed,
or you have been disappointed
several times already,
then thinking you are the
smartest person in class
might not be a good idea because
you might get disappointed
again.
And then we'll talk
a little bit more
about gender in a
different lecture later.
That's a very common theme--
one second-- is that female MIT
students, or in general women,
but in particular also
female MIT students,
are particularly
under-confident.
We don't exactly
know why that is,
but it's a very robust
finding, not just at MIT.
In some ways, then,
there's still a question--
so it's a very nice
observation that in a way,
beliefs can also be a
form of self-motivation.
So if you are really
interested in academic success
and being really good at
exams and so on and so forth,
if you are
under-confident, that can
be a motivator in
saying that you're
really worried about failing.
You're worried about
doing badly and so on.
Then you work extremely
hard, and then you
do better in exams.
You surprise
yourself positively.
That can be an
important motivator.
Of course, that could
also go the other way.
It could be really discouraging.
If you think you're really
terrible at everything,
then you might--
at the end of the day, you
might not study at all anymore,
because what's the point?
So there's a bit of a
trade-off here as well.
And it could be that if you
think that people are-- when
they're under-confident,
that leads to motivation
and it makes them
better at school.
Plus, they're going to
be less disappointed
and get positive surprises.
That could be an explanation.
I think there's a bit
of a question again.
Why is that the case at MIT and
not in the overall population?
But it might have
to do with frequency
of feedback, and school,
and so on and so forth.
And maybe also just with
social norms or other things
that maybe are somewhat
trickier to explain.
I was teaching Harvard
undergrads as a grad student.
I'm not so sure that Harvard
students are under-confident,
to be honest.
I haven't seen the
survey evidence on that,
but my sense is
that MIT students
are more under-confident
compared to Harvard students.
Let's leave it at that.
But I think it's
true if you look
at Caltech and other
type of schools
that are very similar to MIT.
I think-- my guess is
you'll find similar results
in those kinds of surveys.
OK.
So the next thing
we're talking about
is very quickly is what's
called ego utility.
So partly I want to talk about
anticipatory utility, which
was the idea that people
want to look forward
to good things in life.
And therefore, they're--
have inflated beliefs about
what's going to
happen in the future.
A very related aspect is what's
called ego utility, which is--
so just to recap,
inflated beliefs
might be explained by
anticipatory utility
essentially to say higher
ability means better
future prospects, and people
want to convince themselves
that they have high ability.
And therefore, if you
think you're really smart,
that means good things are
going to happen in the future.
But it might also just
be, like, right now,
you're just feeling
better about yourself,
and therefore you have inflated
beliefs about yourself.
So that's often tricky to
distinguish empirically
in the sense of
like, I might just
feel like I'm good looking,
smart, and so on and so forth,
because it makes me
feel good right now.
Or I might want to
hold those beliefs,
because that means
good things is going
to happen in the
future, and I will have
a bright future going forward.
So these things are slightly
tricky to disentangle,
and both of them probably
play an important role
at the end of the day.
So now one thing I'm going to
talk about a little bit more
also later in the semester
is about mental health.
And so there is this
literature that argues
that positive illusions are--
promote, in fact,
psychological well-being.
So that's the
argument that is here,
that overconfident is, in
fact, vital and important
for maintaining mental health.
So overconfident and that
makes people happier.
People are better able
to care for others
if they think they,
themselves, are doing better.
They're better at doing
creative and productive work.
That's also better over
confident helps people
manage negative feedback.
So overall, all of those
things are [INAUDIBLE]
so this literature argues
that overconfidence actually
helps people with
their everyday lives.
In particular, helps
people maintain
a positive-- a
good mental health.
And there's this term called
depressive realism, which
is to say that realistic
expectation might actually be
detrimental to mental health.
So that the world is just
difficult in various ways
and bad things are
happening in many lives,
and if people are not overly
optimistic about what's
going to happen in
the future and so on,
that might be actually bad
for their mental health.
We'll return to this
issue on happiness
and mental health
in a later lecture,
but I wanted to flag
as these things.
They're very much
linked to each other.
And another reason perhaps why
overoptimism might be, in fact,
good or not detrimental is
because not only makes people
happier, but it might
also help people
protect their mental health.
OK.
So then just very briefly,
and this is more like--
there's some research
in some of those things.
Some of this is more anecdotal.
What are some
factors that affects
the extent of positive biases?
So people tend to have greater
biases, in fact, with respect
to prospects and traits that are
personally important to them.
On the one hand,
you might say, well,
people should also be better
informed about those things.
But to the extent that
it affects their utility,
they might be more biased.
If it's stuff that's
really important to you,
you might be more biased
because that's precisely what's
going to make you happier.
Available or imminent
objective information
tends to decrease
biases as in like--
and this is what I was talking
about with MIT students.
When you think about
academic performance,
you get lots and lots of
feedback every single semester.
So in a way, it's more difficult
to be overly optimistic,
or to maintain an overly
optimistic picture
of your academic self if you've
got all these objective signals
over and over again.
So one prediction here
would be that, for example,
if you looked at first,
second, third, and fourth year
students, that perhaps some
of the under-confidence
only comes later
in the semester.
Of course, there's other reasons
why that might not be the case.
Then if feedback about the
prospect or any prospect
is more ambiguous and
subject to interpretation,
biases tend to be greater.
So in particular,
people are particularly
biased in situations
where people
get ambiguous
feedback where you can
interpret things either way.
So either you were really smart
and did something really great,
or you're just lucky.
And people tend to, in
many things in life,
people tend to interpret
sort of lucky things
that happened in their
lives, tend to think
that those are due to skills.
And there's this very nice work
in a book by Robert Frank--
he's at Cornell University-- who
sort of argues that people tend
to interpret a lot of things
that happen in their lives that
really are just mostly luck.
They tend to think that it's
due to their amazing abilities
and so on.
And that's the reason
for that, often,
is that a lot of this feedback,
or a lot of this information
is ambiguous.
You can interpret it either way.
And people like to think that
good things are because they
did really great, and bad
things are because they just
happen to be unlucky.
If people-- and that's
quite interesting.
If people feel like they have
control over the outcomes,
biases tend to be greater.
Expertise sometimes
increases biases,
but not for experts who
get very good feedback.
So meteorologists or the
like who get lots of feedback
all the time, they actually
tend to not be overconfident,
because, again, if you get so
much feedback all the time,
it's hard to sort of
maintain your overoptimism.
OK.
So now one question
you might have is,
well, I showed you a
bunch of data information
on biased beliefs but not
a lot on actual action.
Of course, the testing
behavior, and the Huntington's
disease, and so on
[INAUDIBLE] some actions.
But a lot of the stuff on the
Weinstein and other studies
were just about
self-appointed beliefs.
And one question you
might have is, well,
this is about self reports.
What about your preference
on choices that people make?
So there's some evidence
that's from lab experiments,
and there's some other
evidence that I'll show you
that is about actual choices.
So one very nice experiment
is the paper by Eil and Rao
from 2010.
The way this works is
people are given feedback
about people doing
IQ tests, and they're
rated according to their
physical attractiveness
by others in the study.
And they get feedback
about this IQ test
score and their
physical attractiveness.
These two things are
chosen presumably
because people care
a lot about them.
People care about
how smart they are.
People also care about
how good looking they are.
And then so in the
study, the authors
elicit people's prior beliefs,
the beliefs at the beginning
before they receive information,
about a rank between one
and 10.
So people are put in groups
of 10 and then asked about,
in a group of 10
people, how do you
think you rank
compared to others?
And then people get
some information,
and they get, in particular,
bilateral comparisons
with another participant
in the group.
And then the authors elicit
their posterior, so beliefs
after receiving this
information, and also
the willingness to
pay for true ranks.
And broadly speaking,
what the authors find
is there's asymmetric processing
of objective information
about the self.
In particular, when people
receive positive news,
so when somebody says
you've been compared
to another person in the study
and you're better looking,
or you have a better IQ
score than this other person,
people tend to be
roughly Bayesian,
as in they tend to be pretty
good at actually updating
based on that information.
In contrast, when people
receive unfavorable news,
they tend to essentially
discount the signals,
and they tend to
essentially not really
react to that information.
So that's very much
consistent with people
who are very happy to
receive positive feedback
and actually good
at integrating it,
as in they're good
at doing the math
as a Bayesian
would want them to.
But once they get negative
feedback, they essentially
mostly just discount that
information, presumably
and very much consistently
with motivated beliefs.
People tend to want to have
positive images of themselves.
There's also some evidence
of people's willingness
to pay for information if they
think the information will
be good, and not willing
to pay for information
if they think the
information will be bad,
so if they're low in the ranks.
Again, people want to hear
good things about themselves,
and they learn more or they're
willing to learn more when
they receive positive news.
They're also willingness--
willing to pay more
for information that they
think will be positive.
There's some other evidence
that's similar to that.
There's a very nice-- or a
similar paper by Mobius et al
that's very similar
to Eil and Rao.
There's some very nice
work by Florian Zimmermann
in motivated memory.
So that paper argues
that it's not just
about when people
update immediately.
So when people are given
positive or negative
information, they
update differently.
But what Florian Zimmermann
shows is that in his work
that when people are given
this information, in fact,
in his experiment
there is no asymmetric
updating in the short run.
So when people are given
this information about-- this
is about how they did
in a test in Germany,
in the short run people seem
to actually be not overly
optimistic in their updating.
But then a month later when
the author goes back to people
and asks them about the
information that they have
received and their
beliefs, people
tend to remember
positive signals more
than negative signals.
And that suggests
that memory can
play an important role in the
formation of motivated beliefs.
When stuff happens,
good stuff, people
remember more, and bad
things, not so much.
Now those are all
lab type experiments
where people are incentivized
to give correct answers.
But in a way, it's
somewhat contrived.
There's also quite a bit of
evidence in the real world
setting, in particular, when
it comes to finance or trading
behavior.
For example, there's Barber
and Odean that shows that--
looks at overconfident
small scale investors.
Men, for example, tend to
trade a lot more than women.
We also know from
other settings that men
tend to be more overconfident
than women, and those men,
then, also lose more money
or make less money plausibly
due to overconfidence.
With this type of evidence,
it's often a little tricky
because it's hard to say,
is it to due to gender?
Is it due to overconfidence
and maybe other things
that are correlated with this?
But there's quite
a bit of evidence
on that kind of behavior that
essentially overconfidence
leads to worse decision here
in this case trading decisions.
There's also a very nice paper
by Ulrike Malmendier and Tate
on managerial hubris.
They have a clever
way of identifying
overconfident managers, which
essentially is managers that
are overconfident-- they
are holding stock options,
if they own stocks.
So you're not
supposed to do that,
and you will most likely do that
only if you think your company
is going to do really great
compared to other companies.
Instead, you exercise-- you
should exercise your stock
options and diversify and
not to be overly invested
in your own firm.
But if you think that
you're really great
or your firm is really
great, you [INAUDIBLE]..
And precisely those
overconfident managers
engage their business
in more mergers,
and those mergers, Malmendier
and Tate show, in fact,
are not good.
People tend to do
too many mergers that
essentially destroy
value, presumably
due to overconfidence.
So there's that kind
of evidence as well.
So overall, we think
there's quite a bit
of evidence of people
systematically holding
overoptimistic beliefs.
And those overoptimistic beliefs
are affecting people's choices
in a way that makes
them worse off.
In some ways, in particular,
in finance choices
where people tend to
lose or destroy value.
OK.
Any questions on
this before I move
on to heuristics and biases?
OK.
So then we talked about three
of our four issues here already.
The last thing that we
haven't talked about very much
is to say Bayesian learning
is just really hard,
and people might
just not be good
at it, not for any
motivated reasons
or because of any utility
reasons [INAUDIBLE]
anticipatory
[INAUDIBLE] utility.
But it just might be
really hard to do,
and people essentially
use heuristics
because it's too hard to compute
these things on their own.
Now we talked about this
already quite a bit.
Lots of economic choices
are made under uncertainty.
Almost anything in life
involves some uncertainty,
so we need to know something
about the likelihood
of relevant events.
And if you decide which
topic in the course
to focus on when you
study for an exam,
and you only have like
one night to do so.
If a basketball coach decides
whether to leave tired players
in the game, you kind make
some probabilistic judgment
about which player
is going to be best.
Many medical, managerial,
educational, career decisions,
essentially all those
kinds of decisions
are involving probabilities
based on probability
of good things happening, some
probabilities of bad things
happen, and you need
to make some estimates
about those probabilities.
Now how do make
individuals probabilistic
judgement of this kind?
So far when we talked
about risk preferences
earlier in the semester,
we essentially looked at,
how do people make these choices
for given probabilities, right?
That was essentially
prospect theory.
That was about Kahneman
and Tversky, 1979,
which was how do people
think about risk?
And what we always assumed
was that the probability
distribution was given.
There's a 50% chance of
something good happening.
something bad happening,
and how do people make
those kinds of choices?
What does their utility
function look like?
Now we're going to talk
about, how do people
learn about such probabilities?
How, in the first
place, do they update
what probabilities are like?
Which is, of course,
a very important input
in their decision making.
Now, this is based on pioneering
work by Kahneman and Tversky,
even earlier than the '79 paper.
This is, in particular,
a paper on 1974,
which is in the reading list
and on the course website.
Now first, I want
to start with--
and this is important
in behavioral economics
to acknowledge and
try to emphasize
people are pretty rational and
pretty good in various ways,
in the sense of people
get lots of things right.
In particular, people
are pretty good in terms
of broad directions of
people's probability judgments.
Here's a very simple example.
Imagine you're deciding whether
to see the new James Cameron
movie.
This could be a
James Cameron movie.
It could be a Korean
drama or anything else.
People think about they
want to watch something new.
Well, how are you
going to do that?
Well, you can read
some online reviews.
You hear some opinions
from your friends.
You look at some Rotten
Tomatoes or other ratings,
and then you try to make
those kinds of choices.
And so you start-- maybe you
probably would, like, OK,
have I seen a James
Cameron movie before,
or I said Korean drama,
whatever you're interested in.
have I seen something
like this before?
How much did I like
the previous one?
That could be your prior
that you start with.
And then you get these
other pieces of information
of online reviews, various
opinions from friends,
or a Rotten Tomato ratings,
and how do you use those, then?
What do you do with those?
So essentially what
you're going to do
is you take some-- you
got some prior, which
is about James Cameron movies
or whatever to start with.
And that's like that--
that's what you use to start
with in the first place.
And then you get essentially
these pieces of information.
And if they're positive
pieces of information
about those specific movies,
then you're going to update up.
And if they're bad, if
your friends don't like it,
as you said, they update that.
Notice that it could also be
that you have a friend who
has terrible taste in
movies, and if that friend
does not like a movie, that you
update the other way and so on.
So it doesn't need to be that
your friend's movie ratings are
positively correlated
with yours.
That could still be informative.
If somebody has terrible movie
taste and likes something,
that could be actually good
news for the particular movie.
But exactly-- this
is what I have here.
Essentially what
you're going to do
is a version of this would
be you start with your base
rate or your prior.
And then essentially you use the
various pieces of information
and then adjust your
probability up or down.
Suppose you have to sort
of [INAUDIBLE] willingness
to pay or your probability
of seeing the movie
or doing other things, or
your probability of liking
the movie, you adjust
it up or down based
on the different pieces of
information that we get.
And so generally
people are pretty--
and this is a pretty
reasonable and mathematical,
mathematically
well-founded procedure.
This is actually pretty close
to what a Bayesian would do.
So people are actually
pretty good at this.
They're pretty-- they
understand the basics of forming
likelihood estimates.
They know the direction
in which features
a baseline likelihood
and available information
should affect estimates.
So overall, people
are pretty good.
Now what's much harder to do is
not just a direction, but also
the extent to which
you should update.
That is to say, people know
which direction to move,
as in like if you and
I like similar movies
and I tell you this
movie was great,
it's pretty clear that
you should move upwards.
But what's much
harder to understand
is by how much should
you move upwards
in your estimate of how good
the movie or the probability
that you like the movie is.
And that's true for
many things in life.
People are pretty good
at the direction in terms
of where to move up or down.
What they're much
worse at is how far
to adjust their estimates.
And that's where they
should be using Bayes' Rule,
but that's extremely
cognitively demanding.
And so in many situations people
tend to not get that right.
Now, just to sort of remind
you, and I think in recitation
you discussed this as
well, what is Bayes' Rule
or how does Bayes' Rule work?
Let me go very
quickly through that
and then focus on
that next evidence.
Here's one example.
Suppose you have a coin that
you start off thinking as a--
is fair with probability of 2/3.
That means the coin is
biased towards heads
or the coin is heads and tails.
It's biased towards heads with
probability 1/3, in which case
heads comes up 75% of the time.
Now if you flip the coin
and it comes up H, heads,
what's the probability
of that, that it's fair?
Clearly, it should be 2/3,
because you've got some signal,
but by how much
should you adjust
is actually very hard to do.
So you can think about
this in your head,
and you realize it's
actually kind of hard to do,
unless you can
actually write it down.
So suppose you had to make
a very quick decision.
In particular, it's
actually very hard
to do this quickly on your own.
You can do this particularly
with one signal,
but suppose you
get several signals
and it gets much harder
and harder over time.
Now how would you do this?
You can sort of-- in
this particular case,
you can do a graphical
illustration.
Again, I'll do
this very quickly,
but you can read
about it overall.
You can think about,
there's sort of two types
of coins or like urns.
There's a fair coin
that's represented
by an urn with equal number
of heads and tail balls.
And there's an
unfair coin, which
is represented by an urn in
which 75% of the balls are H.
So you don't know
whether the coin is fair,
so you don't know which
urn you're drawing from.
And one way to
think about this is
imagine you're drawing
from an urn that
contains both of those urns.
Of course, you need to
then also take into account
the probability of the
fair ball being 2/3.
So the fair urn has twice as
many balls as the unfair one.
So you can sort of
represent it in that way.
And then suppose you
draw a ball randomly
and it's H, what's
the probability
that it came from the fair urn?
Then again, if you've taken
probability classes and so on,
that should be relatively
simple for you to calculate.
But here in the graphical way,
you can look this very simple.
There's essentially
seven red balls.
There's four in the fair coin
and three in the unfair coin.
So the probability that it
came from the fair coin is 4/7.
Similarly, if you draw a
T, then the probability
it came from the fair
urn is 4/5, right?
And that's, in some sense--
you can write down the math,
and it's pretty clear and so on.
But in a way, it's hard to do
this in your head in the sense
that you know it should
be lower than 2/3,
but how much lower and
how much should you adjust
is actually kind of hard.
And here the answer
happens to be 4/7.
And so here's sort of the
formal way of doing this.
I'm not going to go into this.
But trust me, the answer is 4/7.
Now, even this simple
example of Bayes' rule,
maybe it was very
simple for you.
But it's somewhat
difficult to follow
in the sense of would you have
gotten the first sentence right
immediately if I
gave you 10 seconds?
Maybe, maybe not.
But probably quite a few of
you would have gotten it wrong.
Now, in addition,
then, if you try
to apply these kinds of rules or
the base rule in new situations
with multiple pieces of
different information,
it's far more
difficult. Suppose I
told you to draw like 17
times and get those signals
and without replacement and
with replacement and so on.
Things would get way,
way more difficult.
And the urn example is, in
fact, a much easier one.
Because there are at least
I'm telling you exactly what
the probabilities are.
But in many
real-world situations,
you don't even know that.
A friend telling you the
movie is good or bad,
it's not clear how
to read that signal,
how do you think about
that signal as a whole.
So but most people don't
know the precise rule
of Bayes' rule.
I guess, at MIT,
most students do.
But in the general
population, people don't.
And even if they do,
they can't or don't want
to think so hard in many cases.
So what people do instead,
they use intuitive shortcuts
to make judgments
of likelihoods.
Now, that's a good thing.
So we want people to use these
shortcuts because otherwise
they will just freeze and not
be able to make any choices.
And so, in some sense,
it's good that people
are sort of simplifying problems
and they make some choices
quickly.
So in some sense, it's good.
But it also leads to
systematic mistakes.
Because in some sense,
you can use shortcuts.
And they help you to get
things approximately right.
But now, if we can
understand their shortcuts,
then we can also
understand, potentially,
their systematic mistakes.
So what people
tend to do is they
focus on one or a small
set of the situations
at hand that seems
most relevant.
They focus on that to
make their decision.
And often, then,
they systematically
neglect other more
complicated other issues
of the situation, which
makes the likelihood
of their estimates
typically incorrect.
And now the question is,
can we sort of understand
what people focus on?
And can we understand what
causes these systematic biases
to sort of make clear
predictions on how
people do things wrongly.
And then, perhaps, if
you want to help people
make better choices,
you can provide them
with valid information as well.
Now, one particularly
interesting issue
is sequences of random outcomes.
So as I just showed you,
if you sort of drop balls
from an urn, that's a
very relevant situation,
not because people in the real
world in real-world situations,
drop balls from urns, but rather
because, in many situations,
you do actually get
repeated signals over time
that you should use to update.
So an investor might
observe past performance
of mutual funds before deciding
which one to invest in.
A patient of a doctor
might observe the outcome
of prior surgeries
before deciding
whether to undertake the surgery
or which doctor to choose.
A coach can observe the recent
performance of a basketball
player before deciding whether
to put the player in the game.
There's lots of kinds of
situations where people
get repeated signals
over time and then
have to try to infer
likelihoods of probabilities
of certain events to happen.
So that's a very common
thing in the world
that we should try
and understand.
Now, one systematic pattern
that we see in the world
is what's called the
gambler's fallacy.
That's the false belief that, in
a sequence of independent draws
from a distribution,
an outcome that
hasn't occurred for a while
is more likely to come up
on the next block.
So the important part and
what's doing a lot of work here
is independent draws.
Suppose there's a
distribution of outcomes
and there's independent
draws, which
means that, essentially, what
happened in the last two,
three, or four draws
should not have
any effect on what's going
to happen in the next draw.
So if you play roulette or
any sort of poker or the like,
if you get read several
times in a row, that
has exactly no impact on how
likely it is that red or black
is coming up in the next draw.
But people tend to have sort
of this almost like folk
knowledge of, well, if
red came up a few times,
now black is due, and
the other way around.
And that's true in many
different situations.
But the important part
here is that there's
a sequence of independent draws.
So as to say, these
are situations
where the probability
distribution is actually null.
That is to say, when you play
roulette or you go to a casino,
it's not like you need
to learn about what's
the probability that the
roulette is fair or not.
You know that there's some
monitoring and so on in those
situations.
You know, essentially, that the
chance of getting red or black
is the same.
And yet people tend to make
these kinds of updates.
There's a nice paper
by Gold and Hester,
an old paper that shows
this quite nicely,
in which subjects are
told the coin with a black
and a red side would
be flipped 25 times.
And the experiment is
slightly sneaky here,
because essentially
actually they
reported people a predetermined
sequence of events.
So there's some
deception involved here,
which is a little bit
trickier but it's mostly fine.
So what they see is
essentially the subject
sees 17 mixed coin flips.
So they see a sequence
of coin flips.
It's red and black and so on.
And then, at the end of
it, you see essentially
one black and four reds.
And so, again, this
is supposed to be
like independent draws,
which to make this case,
in this experiment, they sort
of rigged the last five draws,
which is not quite ideal.
But let's just go
with this for a bit.
And so what essentially
people see in this experiment
is mostly evidence
of red and black
where roughly red
and black is even.
If anything-- so
the 17 are mixed--
these are actually draws--
if anything, people saw more
red than they saw black.
Then, on the 23rd
flip, after seeing
these 22 flips to start
with, the participants
were given a choice
between 70 points
for sure or 100 points if the
next flip was their color.
And points are
essentially stuff they
can get money for eventually.
And so now it's randomly chosen
whether half of the subjects
color was red and half
of them was black.
And so now the propensity to
take the 70 points reveals
the beliefs about the odds
that the next flip would
be their color.
So if you think
the probability is
50%, which is kind of like,
given the information that you
got, you should probably
roughly think it's 50%,
and if you're risk-averse
in particular,
you should truly choose
the 70 points for sure.
Because an expectation, if you
get p times 100, if it's 50%,
you get, essentially, 50.
So you're only got to choose the
"100 points if the next flip is
your color" if you really think
your color is likely to occur.
And in particular if your
probability of that occurring
is like 70% or higher,
notice that that even
assumes risk neutrality.
So if people are
risk-neutral, if they
think the probability is 70%,
they should be different.
And again, if
they're risk neutral
and they choose number 2 here,
their color, well, that's
only the case if they think
the probability of the color
occurring is higher than 70%.
And so given the
evidence that they saw,
it's going to be
rarely the case that--
or people should really, given
the evidence that's there,
the best thing they
can do is essentially--
or the thing is set up
such that they really
should choose number one.
But of course, the
idea is here, if people
think that it was four times
red, so now black is due,
the prediction would be that
people would be more likely
or will choose item number
2 if their color is black.
And so 24 of 29
red subjects chose
to take the sure thing, which
essentially is option 1 here
that I showed you.
And eight of 30 of the
black subjects did.
So these are essentially the
people who choose their color.
So if people have
black as their color,
they essentially
choose this option
because they really
think now black is due
because there's been
essentially four reds in a row.
Now, again, if you're
told-- and that's
a little bit in play
in this experiment--
about these being independent
events, which for coin flips,
really they should be
independent events,
that doesn't make any sense.
You should, if
anything, think red
is more likely
because the coin might
be sort more likely to be red.
But sort of thinking
that black is more likely
surely is not a good idea.
And it might essentially
make you lose money.
Now, there's some
interesting variant
of this for which they
set, for some variants,
the 23rd coin flip was delayed
by some time, 24 minutes.
And what they then
find is, in fact,
weaker evidence of what's called
the gambler's fallacy, which
seems to say that once you
let the coin rest for a while,
people seem to think
that letting the coin
rest for a while, which sort of
makes it more likely, I guess,
that the streak continues, or
less likely that essentially
black now is the case.
So people seem to these fairly--
and I think that's fair to
say-- irrational beliefs
about or biased beliefs about
what's going to happen next.
And that seems to be easily
swayed by even relatively
small things.
It's like the coin
needs to revert.
But if you wait for 24
minutes, not so much anymore.
There's quite a bit of work on
the gambler's fallacy overall
in various settings.
That's just one setting
to illustrate this.
There's quite a bit of
other work in that area.
And it's a fairly robust
finding that people
have found in the literature.
Now, a second pattern
that people find
is what's called the
hot-hand fallacy.
That's the idea that, in
particular basketball fans
or other sort of
types of sports fans--
fans, players, coaches--
believe that there
is systematic day-to-day
operations in players'
shooting performance.
And that's for
basketball, but it's also
true for other sports.
So the idea is that the
performance of a player
may sometimes be predictably
better than expected
on the basis of the
player's overall record.
And so what people would
say is, well, the player
is on fire today or is a
streak shooter and so on.
And so the idea is
that "on fire" today
means that he or she is more
likely to hit his or her shots
than on other days.
So that's to say
prediction is that made
shots should cluster together.
Like on one day you happen
to be really good, maybe,
in the first half.
The second half, and conditional
of having made a few shots,
the next shot should be
more likely than sort
of the unconditional
probability.
There's lots of
work on this issue,
starting by Gilovich and
Vallone and Tversky in 1985.
People have gone back and
forth between saying in fact
there is sort of such a
thing as a hot hand or not.
The initial claims
were essentially
there is no such thing.
People believe that
there's a hot hand going on
and players are really running
hot, but in fact, they're not.
Some other evidence
later showed maybe
there is actually such a thing.
And it was contradicted again.
So it's kind of complicated.
But overall it seems to be
that people tend to be--
players, fans, and
so on-- tend to be
quite overoptimistic about the
hot-handed streaks happening
in reality.
Now, one question is that that
seems kind of odd in some ways.
And so, on the one hand,
the hot-hand fallacy
and the gambler's fallacy seem
to be opposites of each other.
That is to say, the
gambler's fallacy
is the belief that
the next outcome
is likely to be different
from the previous ones.
If I show you, if
you're gambling,
you've got like four
reds, now you say
it's going to be black next.
So if you have three
heads, then you
think that your coin is going
to show some tails, that's
essentially saying you saw a
bunch of outcomes of one kind,
the next one will
likely be different.
On the other hand, then hot-hand
fallacy is saying, well,
it's a belief that
the next outcome
is likely to be similar
to the previous ones.
Now, what's going on here,
you can think of both of these
as a consequence of
what's called the belief
in the law of small numbers.
Now, what is that?
You should all know the
law of large numbers, which
is, in large samples
of independent draws
from a distribution,
the proportion
of different outcomes closely
reflects the underlying
probability.
So essentially once you
have sufficiently many draws
from some distribution,
the distribution
will converge to what
you're drawing from.
Now, what's the belief in
the law of small numbers?
Well, it's the belief
that, in small samples,
the proportion of
different outcomes
should reflect the
underlying probabilities.
So usually, the law
of large numbers, it's
called the law of large
numbers because you
need the large number of draws.
That's why it's called that way.
But people seem to think
that the law of large numbers
also applies to small samples.
And so how does it
explain our puzzle?
Well, then there's a question
of does the person know
the underlying distribution?
So if you think you know the
underlying distribution--
for example, if you think for
sure that the coin is fair
or the roulette table is not
cheating you, you might say,
well, roughly, I
should see as many reds
as I should see blacks or
I should see as many heads
as I should see tails.
And so now, if I have a
sample of like four draws,
if I already have
like four heads,
then I might sort of think,
in that small sample,
I need to see, essentially,
a roughly equal fraction
of heads and tails.
And therefore, if I
have seen four reds,
the next one is due to be black.
And of course that's not
true because essentially
the large number does not
apply to small samples
because it's called the
law of large numbers
and not the law
of small numbers.
But mistakenly, people
seem to think the law
of small numbers applies.
In contrast, if the person
does not know the distribution,
the belief in the
law of small numbers
can lead to the
hot-hand fallacy.
That's to say, if
you're trying to learn
about a distribution of shots
or the underlying probability,
if you see some good events in
a row, if you see three heads
or tails and so on, if you
see a player making three
shots in a row, you might sort
of try to infer, oh, today
is a good day or a bad day.
And people tend to over-infer.
They tend to think they can
learn more from these three
shots than they actually do.
Really, to be able to
estimate whether a player is
running hot on a given day,
you need quite a few draws.
But people think, if a
player makes three shots,
that already means that
his probability of making
good shots on that day are way
higher than it actually is.
So essentially people
mistakenly seem to over-infer,
from a small number
of observations,
what the underlying
probability distribution is.
And in that sense, the belief
in the law of small numbers
can lead to the hot-hand
fallacy as well.
So these are essentially two
very different conclusions
that seem to come from
the same underlying issue.
Then the last pattern
I'm going to show you--
by the way, there's more
patterns such as those,
but I'm sort of just showing
you three of them to give you
a sense of what's going on.
Remember the example
that I showed you
in the first lecture, which was
a question about base rates,
base-rate neglect, which is the
question about 1 in 100 people
have HIV.
If we have a test that is 99%
accurate, if a person tests
positive, what's the probability
of having the disease?
And so I showed you this before.
The true answer is 50%.
But quite a few if
you answered 99%.
And the plausible explanation
is that people probably
forgot to take into account how
few people in the population
have the disease to start with.
And so this is what's called
the base-rate neglect.
When people are given some new
information, people tend to--
in this case, I guess, a
test being 99% accurate,
people tend to focus on
that piece of information.
They tend to neglect the
underlying base rate, which,
in this case, is like
one in 100 people
tend to have the
disease to start with.
And again, that's a
natural consequence
of focusing too much
on one central aspect
offhand, which is the
99% accuracy of the test.
In a way, that,
again, can be useful.
But it's sort of
systematically getting people
to make wrong choices.
And there's quite
a bit of evidence
showing this in the literature.
And here's, again, what
you should be doing
and here's the
probability of this.
Trust me that this
really is 50%.
Now, the last piece
here, in terms
of biases or systematic biases,
what I showed you so far was,
well, people have a hard time
making right choices even
in simple informational
environments.
Now, two-dimensional learning
is even more complicated.
And what I mean by
two-dimensional is to say,
if you try to learn about
news or the accuracy of news,
if you watch news
online or anywhere else,
you don't need to only learn
about somebody gives you
some information and
you try to update based
on that information,
but rather you
also need to learn
at the same time
about the accuracy of
the piece of information
that's given to you.
That is to say, if you watch
something online, any article,
not only you need to
sort of understand
what to learn from
that information,
that piece of
information, but you also
need to understand
the underlying source
Of it.
And there's quite a
bit of work recently
on fake news and the question
on, can people in fact
detect fake news?
Does it have to do with
partisanship in particular?
So you might think that
Republicans or Democrats one
certainly news to be true.
So you might sort of
think that Republicans
are more likely to want to
believe views that are biased
towards Republicans,
Democrats are
more likely to
believe news that are
more likely to be Democrats.
And therefore, they might be
more likely to trust fake news
or fall for fake news.
David Rand, in fact, seems
like it has actually--
and at least in their
work seems to have--
by the way, he's at Sloan, in
marketing, in the marketing
group--
he seems to find that it's less
about partisanship but rather
about people being
not paying attention
and being somewhat lazy
and making their choices.
And once you draw
their attention to,
here's an article
that might be fake,
people might seem to be
actually quite good at learning
about the accuracy of it.
Now let me just
summarize for a bit
and then see whether
there's any questions.
So what I've shown you is
essentially using Bayes' rule
is difficult, or I gave
you some sense of it.
I showed you three
systematic deviations
from Bayesian updating,
which is the gambler's
fallacy, the hot-hand fallacy,
and base rate neglect.
These are all well known
deviations from Bayesian
learning.
Now, 1 and 2, I
have argued, can be
explained by the belief in
the law of small numbers.
And there are a really important
real-world implications
of those types of outcomes.
For example, one very
nice recent paper--
Maddie talked about
it a little bit
in recitation, but
only very briefly--
is this is paper by Kelly Shue
and co-authors about decision
making by judges, umpires,
and loan officers,
where essentially, if you're
a judge or a loan officer,
you see a bunch of
applications over time.
And then judges seem
to essentially engage
in what's the gambler's fallacy.
That's to say, if they see
three applicants in a row that
happen to be very
good or very bad,
that tends to affect
the following applicant.
That is to say, judges, when
they decide about parole
and so on, if they have given
parole several times in a row,
they might think
the next person who
is in line, if they have granted
parole several times in a row,
the next person then would
be less likely to get parole,
even though of course these
are independent events.
It just happens to be
that one person happens
to be after or before a certain
applicant in a random way.
So there's really
important decisions
that the gambler's
fallacy might affect.
And more recently, when you
think about base-rate neglect,
in some sense, the
example that I showed
you seems to be a fairly
academic example in some ways.
But when you think about--
and I don't want to talk too
much about COVID-19 since you
see that in your life
too much already anyway--
but if you think about
tests for COVID-19,
there is now talk
about antibody tests.
And particularly as tests that
seem to be highly informative.
In some sense, their
sensitivity and specificity,
meaning the type 2
errors are pretty lower.
Their sensitivity and
specificity is very high.
These tests tend to
be highly accurate.
But in fact, how much
you can learn from those
tests is actually very limited
if the overall fraction
of people who are
infected is not that high.
And that's exactly the example
that I just showed you.
If the fraction
of people who are
positive in the overall
population is relatively low,
you are doing a test.
And essentially, receiving
a negative signal actually
is not giving you a lot
of information overall.
And people tend to miss
that part precisely
because of base-rate neglect.
Let me stop here for a second.
That was a little bit fast.
So I want to see if there's
any comments or questions.
And then, only in
the last 10 minutes,
talk a little bit about
heuristics and biases.
And this is what Kahneman
and Tversky really
are very well known for.
So the way to think about,
then, biases and probability
judgments is what we
already discussed.
The starting point
is that applying
the laws of probability
and statistics
is often impossibly hard.
So people use their quick
and intuitive judgments
to make likelihood estimates.
And so there's a seminal
work by Kahneman and Tversky
and lots of subsequent
work that tries
to think about these biases.
If you're interested in
learning more about this,
Thinking Fast and
Slow by Danny Kahneman
is really a terrific book
about thinking about this.
Now, what's a heuristic?
It's an informal algorithm that
generates an approximate answer
to a problem, quickly.
And therefore,
because it's informal,
it's kind of hard to model.
Well, the previous things
that I showed you before--
let me just go
back for a second--
the gambler's fallacy,
hot-hand fallacy,
and base-rate neglect--
here, you can write down models
that capture these phenomena
pretty well.
For example, for the
base-rate neglect,
you could just have a parameter
like how much weight people put
in the base rate,
how much weight
do people put in the new
information that they get.
And then that parameter
will essentially--
you can estimate that
parameter and you
can write down a
model that's not
Bayesian but close to Bayesian.
Similarly, for the hot-hand
fallacy and gambler's, you
can model that
people essentially
apply the law of small numbers.
And again, that's a model you
can write down and estimate.
In contrast, some of the stuff
that I'm showing you next
is much more difficult to
model because in that sense,
some basic laws
of probability do
just not apply
anymore in the sense
that people don't
respect them anymore
when they make their
belief updating.
Let me show you, in a
second, what I mean by that.
But again, heuristics
have a good and bad side.
So they speed up and
make possible cognition.
So they help you make decisions
in your everyday lives.
And without
heuristics, it would be
really hard to make
any decisions overall.
But because they're
shortcuts, they occasionally
produce incorrect
answers or biases.
So these are essentially
unintended side effects
of adaptive processes.
And that makes it very useful
to study heuristics and biases
together.
In the same way as
you would study vision
and optical illusion
together, studying them
jointly is very helpful because
they're sort of the product
or the result of the same thing.
Things are hard.
Therefore, they use heuristics.
And because they
use heuristics, that
leads to systematic biases.
OK, so now I'm going to show
a few of those heuristics just
to give you a sense
of what these are.
One of the most
well-known ones is
what's called the
representativeness heuristic,
which is about Linda.
Linda is 31 years old, single,
outspoken, and very bright.
She majored in philosophy.
As a student, she
was deeply concerned
with issues of discrimination
and social justice
and has also participated in
anti-nuclear demonstrations.
The question becomes, then,
rank the following statements
from most to least probable.
And so here's a statement.
You can read about them, all
sorts of different things.
In particular, what Kahneman
and Tversky are focusing on
is items 6 and 8.
And item 6 is "Linda
is a bank teller"
and item 8 is "Linda
is a bank teller
and is active in the
feminist movement."
Now, one thing that
should be clear
is that 6 is more
likely to an 8,
because essentially 8 is sort of
conditioning on two statements,
while 6 is only
conditioning on one.
So if Linda is a number
8, of course it's
implied that, if she's a bank
teller and something else,
of course then she
also is a bank teller.
So should always be the case
that 6 is more likely than 8.
But what people tend to
do quite consistently
is that, in fact, people rank
it more likely that Linda
is both a bank
teller and a feminist
than that she's a bank teller.
And there's quite a
bit of work on this.
And showed this in various ways.
But essentially it's
what's it the violation
of the conjunction
law, which is a very
basic law of probability.
And precisely because it's such
a basic law of probability,
it's hard to actually model
this because essentially you
can't use simple
things that should
be true in probability theory.
There's some potential
concerns about this,
people misunderstanding this.
But there's a subsequent
experiment that essentially
shows that that's not the case.
Now, what's going on here
is what Kahneman and Tversky
called the representativeness
heuristic, which people
essentially use similarity or
representativeness as a proxy
for probabilistic thinking.
So based on the
available information,
people form a
mental image of what
Linda might be like and then ask
about how likely it is that--
for example, she's
a schoolteacher--
they might ask them how
similar is my picture of Linda
to that of the school teacher?
And so that turns this
similarity judgment
into a probability judgment.
So here, of course, the
example is very much
rigged in the sense of
they were asking things
about discrimination,
social justice,
and anti-nuclear
demonstration and so on, which
made people think, well, that's
a person that's likely to be
part of the feminist movement.
And then people focus on that
when making these choices.
And they forget the fact
that, essentially, 6
must be, by definition,
more likely than 8.
So that's a common
thing that people do.
So there's quite a bit
of evidence of that.
And again, that's a very
reasonable heuristic.
And it probably
works in many cases.
But it also leads to very
predictably bad choices.
And it's a poor predictor
of true probability
in several situations.
Similarly, what's called
the availability heuristic,
people assess the
probability of an event
by ease of which instances
or occurrences can
be brought to mind.
So when you ask
people, for example,
about are there more suicides or
homicides in the US each year,
people will think about
suicides and homicides
that they can recall.
They might think about what
they watched on TV and so on.
And they judge the
frequency of each
based on how many
instances they can recall.
And people will be much more
likely to recall homicides
because they are much
more salient in the world.
And that leads people
to think that murders
are way more common, which
in fact is not the case.
Again, it's a very sensible
heuristic that people use.
More often than not, it's
easier to recall things that
are more common or probable.
So that's reasonable overall.
But again, there
are, predictably,
things that are
then more salient,
that get more
attention, people tend
to think they're much more
likely than they in fact are.
Let me skip the familiarity
and anchoring and adjustment
and just sort of like conclude.
So what have you learned
about beliefs overall?
So we studied
several reasons why
people might miss
information and fail to learn
we talk about attention.
Attention is limited,
and therefore they
might miss things.
You talked about, why might
they miss important things?
Well, because they might have
wrong theories of the world.
Then we discussed people
might derive utility
from wrong beliefs and
therefore might actually not
want to learn, or might
be systematically engaged
in trying to deceive themselves.
And then we talked
about people who might
be bad at Bayesian learning.
Now, what's important
here, I want
you to take away it's important
to understand these underlying
reasons why people
are misinformed
because that might lead
to vastly different policy
implications.
For example, if you were to
make information salient,
make sense, if you
think people miss
information and important
things in the world--
so if you, for example, think
that people just might not
be aware of the fact that
certain foods have more
calories than others, then
making that information very
salient to people when
they purchase things,
drawing their attention
to that stuff,
could be really
important and could
be really powerful in helping
people make better choices.
Or if they have wrong
theories of the world,
they think calories
are not that important
or if they miss the fact
that smoking causes cancer,
well, then we should really sort
of draw their attention to them
and help them understand it.
And that's what
a lot of labeling
and a lot of making things
salient often is about.
Now, but, if people
don't want to learn,
if people actually
have motivated beliefs
in certain ways, and in fact
they know that, in some ways,
deep down inside, they know the
relevant information already--
smokers, for example,
might know exactly
that smoking is
bad for the health.
So providing them with
information about smoking
will not actually
make them learn.
Or like if you wanted to give
somebody information about how
to best take care of
your health when it comes
to Huntington's, well that's
not helpful if the person
doesn't actually want to believe
that they have Huntington's.
They're never going to
read what you send them
if they want to maintain
their positive image
about their positive
beliefs about their health.
And in fact, when people
derive actually from beliefs,
correcting those beliefs
can make them worse off.
If somebody wants to
believe that for the next--
they know the
probability of having
Huntington's is
reasonably high, but they
want to maintain the
beliefs that they're healthy
and they want to be happy
for the next 10 or 20 years,
and then maybe, at some point,
the disease will break out.
But their choice is they want
to think that they're healthy
and they do not want to
adjust their behavior.
So who are we then to tell them
otherwise that's their choice?
If it makes them less
happy, we might actually
make them worse off.
So in some ways,
there's at least
some argument for
respecting people's choices
if they want to be deluded, if
they want to delude themselves,
and the consequences are
not severe in the sense
of these situations
where they can't really
do much about that, then in
fact leaving people uninformed
might be the right thing to do.
And then understanding
systematic biases
based on kind of help
improve decisions.
That's, in some sense,
a lot less controversial
if you think that people
are systematically
making wrong choices
because they learned wrongly
and they just have wrong
information in their heads,
sort of providing them with
the correct information
seems like unambiguously
something [INAUDIBLE]..
That's all I have
on beliefs for you.
Next time, we're going
to talk about projection
and attribution bias.
But I'm also happy to
answer any questions
in the next few minutes that
you have on this lecture
or on the summary
that I just showed you